[Musique étrangère]
plus comme la ville des sales petits
secrets les
gens me paient pour enquêter sur les
activités de ses meilleurs citoyens
Je suis un détective privé je
m'appelle Philip Marlow à
quel point vos enquêtes sont privées
que puis-je faire pour vous j'aimerais  vous pour
trouver mon amant il a disparu sans
dire au revoir
n'avons-nous pas tous
[Musique]
que veut ma fille ma mère était
en images
elle doit penser qu'il y a quelque chose entre
nous
[Musique]
j'entends que vous cherchez quelqu'un
nous sommes tous  cherche quelqu'un je te paierai
mille si tu le trouves pour moi
le puzzle a beaucoup de pièces je ne sais pas
ce que tu vas trouver
je vais dans le terrier du lapin je n'ai pas
peur de t'emmener avec moi  J'aime
cette chose à propos de ne pas avoir peur que
nous devrions être
ils sont tous dans le complot
vous continuerez à chercher parce que vous ne pouvez pas
arrêter la police ne vous touchera pas mais je le
ferai
de tous les gens de Los Angeles qui vous
ne plaisante pas avec, ils sont en tête de liste,
la clé d'Hollywood est de savoir quand
y  notre jeu est terminé tu y vas je
sors vivant
comme moi-même qui gagne Mr Marlow Je ferai
tout pour te mettre en prison
[Musique]
sois tous nos secrets
ton secret
tu devras les garder aussi
[Musique]